[Musique]
et la rapprocher les continents
elle a fait exploser la vitesse de notre
monde
la fibre optique pour la première fois
quand les glaces aux états unis produit
une fibre optique de haute qualité
sa fabrication remonte à cinquante ans
c'était en 1970
l'ingénieur physicien charles kao du
laboratoire stl au royaume uni en a eu
l'idée
quatre ans plus tôt c'est le père de la
fibre optique
il jette les bases de ce qui allait
révolutionner le monde de la
communication par fibre optique dans un
article scientifique publié en 1966 une
découverte qui lui vaudra plus tard le
prix nobel de physique
[Musique]
leur jeu à l'époque et de faire circuler
une onde lumineuse sur de grandes
distances
les ingénieurs n'arrivait pas à
acheminer un signal au delà de 1 à 2 m
les impuretés dans le vert causait des
réfraction de la lumière au point où
l'on perdait vite le signal 30 ko crois
que si l'on arrive à fabriquer un verre
d'une plus grande pureté
le signal restera intact plus longtemps
c'est en 1970 cai groupe de chercheurs
de corning glass réussi l'exploit
il développe une fibre de silice si pure
et transparente qu'elle atténue à peine
la transmission du signal lumineux
la perte moyenne de signal passe de 1000
décibels par kilomètre à 17 puis deux
ans plus tard à 4 décibels par kilomètre
c'est sans précédent
[Musique]
tous les grands laboratoires comme ceux
de bell aux états unis emboîte le pas et
se lance dans la fabrication de fibres
optiques
au milieu des années 70 ont créé les
premiers câbles de télécommunication
composé de plusieurs fibres optiques à
la même époque au canada northern
telecom se lance dans la production de
fibres optiques en décembre 1977
bell canada entreprend ses premiers
essais techniques sur le terrain à
montréal aujourd'hui
cinquante ans après la création de la
première fibre optique de
télécommunications elles forment système
circulatoire de l'information à travers
le monde
dans une seconde s'écoule sans
communication ou aux transactions ne
passe dans ce réseau de fibre terrestre
et rang social nick qui tapissent le
globe